FEMALE SPEAKER: Welcome,
welcome, welcome.
Want to give you a
few words about what
we're doing with this day.
And just so you
know, there's events
like this happening across
the globe at different Google
locations.
So this is just one of the big
conversations we're having.
There's another
in Mountain View,
and then there's a whole
bunch of local conversations
that are happening
today everywhere.
But for International Women's
Day, what we want to celebrate
is raising the visibility of
technical women, recognizing
and celebrating
their contributions,
and then also expanding the
network of women in tech.
And we know that there
are fewer women taking CS,
that there are fewer
women in the CS pipeline,
and that's something we're
really dedicated to changing
here at Google
because we really see
not only wanting to grow and
keep the talent we have here
but also helping to change
the environment for women
in technology overall.
Hey, all right.
This is actually working.
So diversity, something
I do every day.
Just a little bit about
diversity at Google-- we really
prize diversity because we feel
that we can't truly understand
the experience of our
user if we ourselves
are not as diverse as
the users that we have.
And so we all know how
diverse Google's users
are by the faces in this
room and by everyone
that you're related to and
know who also uses Google.
And so we need to reflect that.
We need to know that we
are really representing
the needs, the
desires of our user.
So to do that, we're
looking at diversity
in the work environment.
Diversity's been part of
the conversation at Google
since the beginning.
It's something we have
always talked about,
we have always focused
on, we have always
been conscious about.
One of the things that we
have been doing recently
to continue this
conversation around diversity
is work on unconscious bias.
We know that we all--
everybody have biases.
And so we've been
talking to our Googlers
about the science
of this, making
them aware of what
unconscious bias is
and the impact that it has.
To date, 20,000 Googlers have
gone through that training,
and it's a continuing
conversation
that we're having all
the time to make sure
that this is the most
inclusive work environment
that we can have.
We also want diversity in
the future of what we create,
from a technology perspective.
And so our education,
our scholarship plans,
are really investing in
the future of technology.
We have Generation
Google scholarships
which look to help high school
seniors and undergrads continue
their CS and technical studies.
We work very closely
with Anita Borg Institute
on all of their efforts
around technology
and around promoting
more women in technology.
And then we want diversity on
the web and in our products.
So we really want to make
the web work for everyone,
and we're trying to
make our products more
accessible for small businesses,
for different groups globally.
So one program is
Women on the Web, which
is to increase women's
participation in our Google
business groups and
drive technology-enabled
entrepreneurship opportunities,
and then also help women become
successful by leveraging
the power of the internet.
So we're really
looking at diversity
from all these
multifaceted perspectives
to make sure it's happening
internally, externally,
and that we're growing the
pipeline as we're doing that.
So we really know that women
in the workplace matter.
And research shows that
when we have more diversity,
we come back with better ideas.
McKinsey has done
work on this showing
that when there
are women and men--
but when we have more
equal numbers of women
in top management, they
see a greater return
on their equity
and their earnings.
Catalyst has done work
to show that if you
have three women on
a board, it radically
shifts how that board interacts,
how they make decisions, what
the outcomes are
for that company.
We know that having
more diversity
means we have better
collective intelligence.
And today, we're talking about
it from a gender perspective,
but we're thinking
about that broadly too,
from an age perspective,
from race, ethnicity,
from sexual orientation-- all
of those pieces come together.
Any kind of diversity
really does impact
and increase the collective
intelligence of the group.
And also, we see that there's
economic impacts, right?
We see that when we get those
better products out there,
we get a better return, and
that's certainly important.
And then last but not least,
right, hearts and minds.
It's the right thing to do.
We have an increasingly
diverse workforce coming in.
We know that women
are graduating
at higher rates than
men from colleges.
And so we have to
always be making sure
that we're on the cutting edge
of getting the best talent here
at Google and making sure
that we're representing
the talent that's coming in and
the talent that is out there.
So we are hiring
phenomenal women.
And not that this is just a
little plug-- we are hiring.
You should apply.
Just saying.
It's a great place to work.
But you don't have to.
But you should.
You should.
No pressure.
We'll just keep saying
it throughout the day.
So our goal is to
really change the world.
And I'll tell you a few other
things that we're doing.
We are looking a K through 12.
We have a very robust program.
We have the RISE Awards
and women at Google
that are working to
encourage more girls
to move into computer science.
We see that some of the biggest
impacts on getting girls
into computer science
is seeing that there
are other women in
computer science
and having them talk
about their experiences.
So we make sure that
that's something
we're consistently doing.
Again, we have the
university scholarships
through Anita Borg.
We also have Google
Get a Job, which
is helping women to
study more in CS.
So we're really
making sure that we're
bringing that possible
talent into our sphere.
We know that when
people actually do
come to interview here and when
you come to interview here--
just saying-- that it
makes an impact if you
have an interviewer
who is female.
So we make sure in
all of our interviews
that we have female interviewers
interviewing our candidates
so that there is that more
diverse view from the candidate
perspective.
We also want to
make sure that there
are networking opportunities.
And so we have very, very
robust communities and networks
within Google.
Our Women@Google has
over 4,000 members.
It's very, very active.
We have other groups
for women in tech.
So we're really making
sure that the communities,
that the networking for
women, and for women with men,
are very robust and very active.
Now I get to show
you a fun video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
How cool is that, right?
You can clap.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
Get this-- there we go.
Hey, there we go.
So this is our
wonderful agenda today.
We're going to be hearing from
some really fantastic women
technologists who
are going to talk
about different
aspects of their work
or talk about being
a woman in tech.
And we want to encourage these
to be really interactive,
so the speakers
are going to speak,
and then there will be time for
questions at the end of each.
Just a note-- if you're
going to ask a question,
come up to the mike
so we can hear you.
And we'll just always be
reminding you of that as well.
We will feed you lunch.
That's nice of us.
And so we will at lunch
have some fun activities
to do as well.
And then at the end
of the day, there's
a really cool reception, and
we have these cool little Spiro
balls which I'm just--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Right?
AUDIENCE: They're awesome.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I know, right?
I know.
I just learned about them.
And the fact that I could
potentially program something
is kind of amazing.
So we'll be able to play
with those at the reception.
So if that doesn't
keep you here,
we'll think of something else.
But that should keep you here.
I'm just saying.
Just to give you a sense
of the other events going
on globally-- pretty
amazing, and, frankly,
really impressive.
We had a lot of people who were
super excited about this day
and super excited to
put on different events.
And so we're excited that you're
a part of the New York event.